ما الذي يعنيه سحب الكتيبه
7107 من قوات الاحتياط المشاركه في القتال
في شمال
القطاع يعني كما جاء في تصريح وزير الحرب
الذي قال انه انه العمليات الاساسيه او
المكثفه وانتقلوا الى العمليات المحدوده
لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعتمد على الحرب
المتحركه حقيقه يعني قواته معظمها متحرك
دبابات واليات
وجرافات ومجنزرات
فبالتالي هذه الحركه تعطيه قدره على
الانسحاب من مكان الى اخر لاسباب عديده
اولا يعني لم يحققوا اهدافهم حتى
الان
موجودين تزداد الخسائر في صفوف الجنود وفي
صفوف
المعدات لذلك يحاولون تقليل هذا الانتشار
من اجل تقليل الخسائر وخاصه خصه اذا ما
بقي الجنود وهذا في العلم العسكري معروف
اذا ما بقي الجنود والضباط في مسرح
العمليات دون ان يحققوا اهدافهم وتتراجع
كفاءتهم القتاليه وتتدنى روحهم المعنويه
لا جدوى من وجودهم وخاصه اذا ما كان هناك
خسائر في صفوفهم كما جرى مع لواء الكفير
وقبلها مع اللواء الجولاني في الشجاعيه
ومع وحدات كثيره تم سحبها بدون الاعلان
عنها فلذلك انا بتقديري ايه حتى لو سحبوا
بعض الوحدات ولو قال وزير الحرب انه
سيكتفون ولكنه ايضا كما نشاهد ما زال
يعتمد على سلاح الجو وعلى سلاح المدفعيه
بمعنى ما زال يستخدم سياسه الارض المحروقه
والتدمير الممنهج وحرب الاباده الجماعيه
واستهداف المدنيين العزل هذا يعني واضح من
اسلوب الجيش الاسرائيلي ولم يتغير حتى
الان ام ما هي الانماط القتاليه التي
تلحظها في المعركه الجاريه في مدينه
ومنطقه خان يونس بشكل عام خاصه مع ادخال
وحدات ماجلان ووحده
ايجوز يعني واضح اولا الجيش الاسرائيلي
اسلوبه معروف قصف تدميري والمفروض ان يكون
قصف تمهيدي لفترات محدده حتى تتقدم الجيوش
ولكن اسرائيل منذ 113 اليوم حتى الان وهي
تقوم بقصف تدميري من الطيران ومن المدفعيه
البريه ومن المدفعيه البحريه وتتبعها
الجرافات وتدمر البنيه التحتيه
وتفجر المنازل كما جرى يعني في الجامعات
وفي المدارس وفي اماكن اللواء وفي تجريف
الشوارع والبنيه التحتيه ومن ثم في بعض
المناطق تتقدم القوات الراجله وانا اعتقد
يعني ما زالت حتى الان القوات الراجله ما
زالت تتحصن بالدبابات وبالي بمعنى انها لم
تبتعد عن سلاح الاسناد لا المدفعيه ولا من
الدبابات اما
عما الفرقه 98 التي تقاتل في خان يونس انا
اعتقد انها قبل ان تصل الى اي منطقه وكما
نشاهده لا بد من قصف طيران وقصف مدفعيه
بريه او بحريه وتدمر المنطقه وحتى لو دخل
للجيوش الجنود الى المناطق المبنيه ت
ترافقها ايضا الدبابات وقد لاحظنا كيف قنص
المقاتلين هذه الدبابات وهذا طبعا يعني في
الجيوش لا يستخدم عاده خاصه في المناطق
السكنيه والمناطق الماهوله وفي الحارات
الضيقه ولكن في حاله الجنود الاسرائيليين
وخاصه لواء ايجوز وماجلان ويهل والددو هذه
الوحدات وحدات النخبه وهي يعني معروف انها
ق قاتلت في جميع الجبهات ولكن هذه المره
في قطاع غزه انا اعتقد يعني ج جانبها
التوفيق لان المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعرف
تكتيكاتها وتستخدم هذه التكتيكات في
مواجهه الجيش وكيف غيرت وكانت المقاومه
مرنه في مواجهه هذه الوحدات التي دخلت في
معركه خان يونس من خلال صدك ل ما تطلقه ما
تبثه من فيديو
تظهر
عمليات الاستهداف المباشر
للاليات يعني واضح انه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي عدت نفسها لعمليه طوفان
الاقصى سنوات طويله وهي تتدرب مهارات
ميدانيه ومهارات قتاليه ومعركه عقول وادم
ومعرفه طبيعه العدو الان كل هذه الخبرات و
ما تراكم من خبرات منذ بدايه الحرب البريه
حتى اليوم سواء كانت في الشمال او في
الوسط او في الجنوب تشي بان يعني ال هذه
التكتيكات مبنيه على معرفه حقيقيه لطبيعه
العدو استراتيجيته الحربيه تكتيكاته
العسكريه معلومات امنيه واستخبارات
بالتاكيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه غير منظوره
للجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
منظور للمقاومه لذلك هي تكيفت مع الصعاب
رغم انها الصعاب كثيره جدا والمقاوم
الفلسطينيه لا يعيش في بحبوحه الزمن كما
هو الجندي الاسرائيلي ولكن هو يتكيف تكيف
مع طبيعه الارض الان هو يقاتل صحيح يقاتل
بالانفاق ولكن الاهم من الانفاق اصبح
يقاتل تحت الركام وبين المباني المدمره
وهذه اصبحت وبال على الجيش الاسرائيلي
والجنود الاسرائيليين لذلك هذه تحتاج
تحتاج الى مهارات ميدانيه وتحتاج الى
شجاعه وبساله تحتاج الى تنسيق وتعاون بين
المجموعات حقيقه حتى حتى تنجح هذه
المجموعات لذل لذلك هذه العوامل كلها
اضافه الى استبسال المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
انا بتقديري استطاعوا ان ينصب الكمائن
ينجح فيها ان يقنص الدبابات حتى الدبابات
المتحركه ومعروف بالعلم العسكري انه
الدبابات والاليات المتحركه من اصعب
الاهداف لانها تحتاج الى الموائمه بين
السرعتين سرعه الاليه او الدبابه وسرعه
المقذوف فاذا كانت السرعتين متطابقتين
تكون الاصابه دقيقه وهذا ما جرى بدليل ان
هؤلاء المقاتلين يعني اولا اعصابهم هادئه
معنوياتهم عاليه كفاءتهم القتاليه كذلك
وقدرتهم على الرصد والتتبع ونصب الكمائن
والتنسيق والتعاون عاليه للمستوى